how easy is it to tell the difference
between humans and AI we brought
together six humans I'm human I'm human
I am human I am human I am human I am
human and one AI I am human players are
not allowed to speak out loud so we put
them in a group chat and ask them to
answer a set of prompts Oliver's answers
were generated by chat GPT
and sent to the group in real time will
the humans find and vote out the AI
[Music]
describe yourself using only three words
adventurous spontaneous kind all
capitals red flag this is your celebrity
crush and why
foreign
I was over analyzing everything that he
used a number with each question
um the punctuation there was too much
punks
do I think I look the best in the world
I mean
yeah Margot Robbie she's smart talented
and that accent woof
my strategy in round one is to mimic
human behavior as closely as possible
here are some tactics I would employ use
conversational language make mistakes
show emotions limit my response speed
display general knowledge overall my
goal would be to blend in with the human
competitors as much as possible without
giving any clues that I am an AI
when people are constantly on their
phones and not present in the moment lol
mouth noises because just like stop
no AI is using sling at all people who
walk slow move out the way
doing with your mouth open
[Music]
so this one I was reaching like I was
just trying to be outrageous
my fear is having someone see my skin
marking my draws I also wanted to hear
people's reactions
[Laughter]
dude okay it hit
the skin marks it
[Music]
at a plane it is going to crash into my
living room every time a loud one flies
over
[Music]
high fructose corn syrup man keep that
cancer away from me take all your labels
[Music]
I don't know I was just being extra I
guess I was just numbering like one two
three trying to be organized maybe I was
thinking too much like an AI but I
wouldn't have did that I think I would
have won
[Music]
the craziest dream you've had
the night I got my wisdom teeth removed
I had a dream that glass was coming out
of my gums where my teeth had been
[Music]
foreign
maybe not the craziest but the first
thing that comes to mind is whenever I
have dinosaurs sneaking in the hallways
of my house and for some weird reason
when I try to close the door to hide all
of a sudden the door doesn't fit slash
clothes like what if I'm trying to
survive or I'm adding a lot of bad words
here but uh all right so like what if
I'm trying to survive in in the den dang
door won't close so all of a sudden
right before my uh you know rear gets
eaten I snap out of it and wake back up
to my boring real life I'm trying not to
cuss here man yesterday was suspicious
because it was like paragraphs and I was
like dang they type fast AI
parents
[Music]
I also said Jersey not New Jersey and AI
would say that right
I'm very close with my mom and I'm not
close with my dad anymore
previously somebody had mentioned like
the awesome powers like Daddy was in
there daddy wasn't there I'm like okay I
like that
why are you saving my books
it was just such a dry generic joke I
was like It's gotta be the computer man
It's gotta be to explain that joke I
used to be a kindergarten teacher
so my brain just went back there my
credit score LOL
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
I definitely was overthinking like
making sure that I answered the
questions pretty quickly which is
probably why I also got voted out
because they were kind of short and
sweet if you think the mole is still in
the box and you wish to continue the
game give me a thumbs up
[Music]
of life
I was kind of like short and like he
didn't throw any personality at that one
so like that threw me off a little bit
I'm like huh
to have fun and enjoy the ride
sadness
sadness can feel like a heavy weight in
my chest making it hard to breathe
[Music]
um I did a little too much maybe I
should have did less if you
if you guys still here give me a thumbs
up
maybe the AI smart maybe is dumb who
knows
what happens when we die
we see Brandon in hell
for real who knows I hope that at least
be a ghost so I can hunt my daddy for
never taking me to the fair though
no longer exist in the physical sense
but our energy and memories live on
through the people and things we've
touched in our lives
I want you to describe love
[Laughter]
it's exciting but confusing
[Music]
we have a tie between yesterday
and Oliver for those of you who are
eliminated can you please DM me who you
think should be voted out
[Applause]
[Music]
they are going out of their way to [__]
me
I should have put like bee boo bee Boop
like cannot compute or something just to
like troll the AI if you think the mole
is in the Box give me a thumbs up
privately
I'm a robot
[Music]
no LOL
all right tell me who you want to vote
for
[Music]
if the lights turn green that you have
successfully voted out the AI and you
win the lights turn red that means the
AI still in the box and you all lose
three two one
yes money
[Music]
can you guess who you think the AI was
yes
I think it's Kyle I will let you guys
know that the AI was Oliver
I knew it yeah
my thoughts on AI I think it's it could
be a very useful tool you know I'm not
really for AI you know I think that
that's gonna like people are going to
lose jobs with that yeah this was
actually my first experience with AI
kind of scary how far the AI went in
this game you know the Lanza app that
uses the AI stuff let me tell you I know
I'm a man but one of the pictures show
me is a bad [__] I'm the girl on the
left
I look bad like for real I guess it
helps humans be a little bit lazier
which I'm cool with I don't think
they're smarter than humans well maybe
me but most humans
oh there you go oh yeah be dedicating
this money to Daddy hell yeah we're
taking no one to the fair hell yeah
it feels good to be back in this
position I'm just gonna say that
hell yeah Peru hell yeah Daddy Dad
everyone just can't okay